cuál es la importancia y la influencia
de la fallecida reina en escocia en esta
región
bueno pues ahí hay dos influencias
primero es la personal como bien decía
el reporte su madre elisabeth bone bowes
lyon era de ascendencia escocesa
de hecho la reina isabel cuando era
princesita de los duques de york nace en
la casa de sus abuelos y pues balmoral
es un estado que compró el esposo de la
reina victoria hacia finales del siglo
19 es la casa de descanso entonces de
esa de ese corazón tiene una influencia
personal estamos bueno ya viendo cómo
está en camino ya edimburgo pero cuando
sale de los highlands de balmoral donde
se encuentran donde se encuentra este
castillo hay una zona que se llamaba
laster balmoral se encuentra dentro de
este pueblo y en val astaire pues la
gente los pobladores los comerciantes
los nativos de ahí la conocían
personalmente porque ella se sentía tan
segura y que desde muy joven salía por
supuesto con su escolta hacía sus
compras bueno ella a ellos pero era muy
común verla en su land rover defender
manejar por sí misma ir sola y saludar a
la gente es decir tenía una gran una
gran relación con ellos a nivel personal
y segunda la política la mayoría de los
miembros del parlamento que de los
ministros del parlamento de la gran
bretaña que vienen de escocia son de
aberdeen jairo y de edimburgo entonces
si no hay una relación importante
sabemos que en escocia hay un first
minister también un primer ministro y
que tiene su propio parlamento pero es
gracias a que son parte del reino unido
de la gran bretaña y que se respeta a
esta independencia pero son parte del
reino unido pues el próximo rey jura
bueno juró en su proclamación que
protegerá siempre a la iglesia de
escocia que tiene libertad pues de creer
o no entonces es una relación
política cultural y muy del corazón
sobre todo en esta parte de edimburgo de
aberdeenshire stack balmoral a una hora
a aberdeen y a cuatro horas edimburgo
estos son los tres puntos cardinales de
obviamente monarquismo en escocia ya que
más allá de todas las formalidades
protocolos que por supuesto
caracterizaron no y caracterizan por
supuesto a todas las monarquías y
particularmente quizás a la de la
fallecida de reina isabel usted nos está
mostrando un costado una arista muy
diferente no que también la
caracterizaba por ejemplo con esta
anécdota de ir ella misma manejando el
automóvil y estando en contacto con las
personas escocesas
así es y desde muy joven desde después
desde que era niña o sea que cuando
ellos hicieron la reverencia cuando pasó
el ataúd ya ccoo con el estandarte de
escocia además entonces vimos lo que era
isabel segunda para ellos no si era no
nada más su monarca era su vecina